you are what you are nothing more
nothing less be proud of who you are no
matter
you know god made you so you are what's
yard and you ain't what you ain't
see i was raised in a hall that didn't
even get a road to like the
50s and and you know the food we got
we we had to raise it that's what i said
now when i was
four-year-old or five a little kid
they made a hole just for our
size to hold like you know
taters or in the gardens you know what
i'm saying
that's all we got to do is work in the
garden
and i mean you know well we played by
all stuff like that but
you know we was like well i was raised
in a mountain i mean literally in the
mountains
you know what i'm saying i'd love to
take you to where i was raised and like
they're a big waterfowl oh it's
beautiful
i mean it is it's like uh it ain't like
the combo on files but uh
it's probably more it's even prettier
than that i guess it is but what's it
like growing up in the mountains like
that you're isolated from everybody else
right
yeah but we never got bored uh
we just uh we would build us a sled like
in the winter time and
you know and stay out in the snow
and ride sleds to dark and we'd play in
the creeks with down the creeks up
and or go to the falls and swim and hit
you know
i mean we just uh we we always had
something to do
even though we had nothing there to
build like
wooden wagons you know and
we you know pretty much didn't get toys
till we were
10 10 years old you know i believe when
i got my first bicycle
and you know life was hard but it was
good
it's a great way for a kid to grow up
right right
you wouldn't change it right oh no no
i loved i loved how i was raised really
you know and tell me about your parents
you had
both your parents growing up not well my
mom
and then she went to baltimore when i
was 12 and i stayed with my grandma my
grandpa
and he was like the
the best person in the whole world you
know
and how much how far did you go in
school to my junior year
that was a bad mistake you know dropping
out of school though it really was
is that your biggest regret yeah it is
my biggest regret what what do you cause
i play basketball i was like
i was a real goodbye player you know if
uh
if i'd have stayed in school you know i
probably i might not even
well i ain't gonna say i'd probably move
but you know
i would have a different life you know
what i'm saying
and i left and went to baltimore and i
got there and stayed like three months
and got home sick
and back to the mountains i come
and i've heard that story a lot from a
lot of people here yeah
i got to a bus station at two o'clock in
the morning
and and uh the bus was full so he said
the next bus
is uh you know tomorrow too and i just
broke down and started crying you know i
said please man let me on this bus you
know
cause uh i i'm gonna go home you know i
want to come see my pal pile
and he said well you can sit in the
floor around the steps you know
and he made me a little seat beside his
one and i rode
it was a five-hour drive from baltimore
to pennsylvania
and uh but out of out of
wow just to get back home you know what
i'm saying
i was yeah
we will go swimming every day lock up
greasy
up to the b rock and you know
we just we always have fun you know
but everybody was real poor where was
raised you know
and as a lot of them was alcoholics
a lot of times you couldn't even get up
the holler for them because
you'd pass five or six in the road
passed out on the way up the hall or
you know what i'm saying you'd have to
drag them out of the road to get by
and then hyphen would want to fight you
and
you know about all them all people are
dead now though
you're the cousin of geraldine who i
interviewed yeah yeah
my mom raised me and her mom and her
sisters
i love girl dave yeah it's a rough life
here yeah
but but that struggle seems to make it
yes she raised the five boys
pretty much on her own and i raised
three pretty much a mile
where where is the father well he's in
and out but you know
he went around too much yeah
how far did you go to school to my
junior year
i like one year graduating
and you you raised three kids yeah three
boys
and how did you support yourself
i'd work for my uncle my aunts
just mostly you know wild jobs or go in
a mountain and dig roots uh
you know dig in so you'd consider
yourself a mountain woman
yeah hell yeah there's a lot of mountain
men
but you're alone i love the mountains i
was raised in the mountains
uh i mean i go gin singing
well anymore i'm sort of you know my
feet
uh i'm my heart's bad i can't walk like
i used to but
yeah i go sometimes dig three panels
saying you know
what's the most ever dug at one time was
three pounds
yeah but every day you know good morning
ginseng
and we save it back you know like to
live through the winter on you know what
i'm saying
big yellow root and like a cow wash
and that's certainly got to be hard work
right yeah it's hard
yeah i was a ginsang in a up double
creek one time
and uh i've seen this i thought it was a
big four prong
and got over and there was a copperhead
wrapped around my
left leg and i went to kick it out and
when i did
i jumped and when i jumped i had snot
leggings on up to my knees
but i failed and when i come up i said
oh man i believe that snake bit me
and it bit me right an inch above my
leggings
so you know and i i just sang like
for three hours snake bit but when i got
to the truck and took that legging off
my leg just blowed up i mean you did it
for three
three hours three hours after i got beat
with a snake bite yeah but when i and
then it started hurting my butt and i
was like oh i ain't never gonna get i
was hollering
people by people die from that oh yeah i
stayed in hospital i believe six days
but i didn't go to the er to like 11
o'clock at night you know
that's what made it bad i guess because
i didn't go straight to the hospital
are you ever ginseng i have never
ginseng
yeah you ought to go make a show about
that
[Laughter]
so what do you think of the future of
this region it seems like the drugs have
taken over the younger generation
yeah it really has i mean
people used to smoke pipe you know a lot
of people thinks pot's real bad
i don't see it is my uncle was uh out
loud so he started smoking pot
when he started smoking pot he turned
into a peaceful
quiet worked out time i mean he eat a
lot they got the munchies and just
chilled out but
then you know when that meth come in
here
it's destroyed the whole it really has
destroyed the whole area
which it's everywhere you know but
i've lost so many friends like to
drugs you know
everybody's on something you know what
i'm saying yeah is that something that
you
struggled with as well not now but in
past year once uh you know but it wasn't
math was mine
i got on when my papa died i got on the
nerve pills real bad and that was my you
know
but i got off of them and my boy got
killed three years ago on a four-wheeler
and they'll try to give me xanax
and you know but i i just won't go get
them because i know you know what i'm
saying i don't want to be back on them
because they're the best pill and
they're the worst pill that ever was
made
but you know mostly around here it's
just math or you know
used to everybody drunk and got drunk
and
you know it was alcohol and maybe pot
then you know it went to meth and
stuff like that which you know like
heroin and stuff like that really ain't
in this part of the country bad
what do you think of the future for for
people here
you know because drugs have taken over
if they don't start putting some kind of
business
like work here hey
it's these the little kids ain't got no
hopeiness
and it's part of the they ain't because
ain't you know
a lot of people don't know about you
know how to make money in the mountains
and stuff
they just you know they ain't no way of
surviving like you know
what are you gonna do and they have to
depend on a food stamp or
uh government assistance because
or their kids would starve to death you
know what i mean
i was raised in this hall or what's up
trace branch i was telling you
but up in there you know everybody
raised their own garden but uh
well he uh he was our neighbor
but he was like he was like
afraid of the world or the life so he
built him a little tar shack
you know had a little dirt floor
and they all he had in his little bed
and a
stove and i mean you know
he was happy with that you know what man
you could
build him a maxim and he wouldn't have
lived in it a lot of people like
he was like you know he loved his little
you know tara shack i guess i've seen
i've met a lot of people here now and it
seems like they live a very very simple
life
yeah but they're also very happy yeah
when was growing up
or that's when lfns like all these
interns would come in
and uh they would all um nurses and
stuff would get together my
uncles and all them they they you know
had a bluegrass band
so they would play music without square
dances you know like every saturday
night
and uh we made a lot of friends you know
through that like
one was highly cheaper she's a
veterinarian now in like new york
but uh you know we had
like on saturday nights we had that to
look forward to then we started going to
the wrestling we would do that every
weekend
and that was fun you know but it was
just
you know life was sweet and simple i
guess you know
my papaw my grandma my great-grandma
right now she's
buried right in the top of a mountain
and an old hill road
that used to they used as a road like
you know
travel it like see she would go around
and deliver babies you know these my old
timers when they had their babies
they weren't no nurses that was for
murray breckenridge
so she was a granny woman they called
her and papout said everyone you know
like
sometimes four in the morning somebody
will come you know you're gonna have to
come let's see the
you know so-and-so's or hat and labor
and she would get on her old mule and
and hit them old mountain roads it you
know
takes you from one holler to the next
and
deliver a baby you know and and that was
probably
you know that was my great grandma and
they was like the
like the first settlers really like you
know upstanding
you know like you morgan them old
morgans there's a bunch of them but
and and you know then like in trace
branch
we didn't have a whale so we would uh
you know they'd take like a horse and a
sled
and uh my uncle albert would go around
digging them dug whales for everybody
but we didn't have one so we'll go to
the neighbors
and get water you know fill these big
cans up
in the sleigh and and i remember riding
in the back of that sled you know i love
that you know but that's how we got our
water till
well we got a whale drill probably when
i was 12 years old
or probably 10 but you know and was
probably one of the first ones even had
a drill weld in the holler
because they didn't have electricity
till probably the late 50s
and the man lived on rock houses
he was the one put a road through that
howler so you know they didn't have no
road they traveled the creek bend
these old mountain roads you know my
mama's buried right in the middle of one
of my mountain roads
right now you know yeah it's a very
special part of the country
oh yeah it's real special
i'd like to go show you where i was
raised and see how
you talk about beautiful but it is
beautiful up in there
it's got the files i mean it's it's so
beautiful
everybody thinks it's beautiful i mean
it is you know
and we would oh when it snowed oh that
was you know
we didn't care if it stayed on
year-round then cause you didn't have no
school you know
and i we would get out at daylight on
them old sleds and
and stay would get some coyotes would
build bars up
and you know warm her feet up and
by the fire you know what's your
favorite memory
in your life
my grandpa i guess my grandma
they they was raised you know they
didn't have
electric she raised 12 kids
by you know the sweat of her brow
she uh growled everything they
eat put it away in the file she had a
milk cow that she got up every morning
at five o'clock
probably walked a mile just to milk the
cow
and she done that twice a day you know
just because papaya worked like in the
uh making mining props when they didn't
get paid probably
50 cents a week you know what i'm saying
he didn't get
money nothing hardly you know and the
only thing they got out of a store would
be like
sugar uh because every she made her own
grease
you know or on the lard you know they
raised hogs killed
every winner they would take turns like
two or three different families would
have a hog to kill
this would go help that and kill their
hog you know
then the other would help them you know
and i'll share the meat
and had smokehouses you know
i'd like for you know some people's
doing that right now like living off
grid
i'd really like to do that i mean when i
was little you know
i was little then but i remember how it
was like i'd follow them to milk the
cows you know
now i want drank cow milk probably just
off the
tea you know one second but then
went so we had to drink you know
do you have any regrets yeah i regret
quitting school
yeah yeah and what what's the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
well you can get in trouble real easy so
i learned my lesson about you know
i really can't explain it
trying to i mean
a lesson learned is like
getting out with your friends that you
think is your big buddies
that can get you to do stuff you won't
normally do
and then uh my lesson learned
is there ain't always your friends
you know that try and they're they're
not your friend that tries to get you to
do stuff like that
you know do good in life you know go for
what's right
and you know be good all right
sue thank you so much for sharing your
story you're welcome and good luck uh
good luck in the mountains you'll have
good wheels on that
i'd like that thank you
yeah you give me your number now i need
some glutens
you